Infinity
What is Infinity
Infinity is really cool
It is about as big as it gets
U cant really put a name to it because that limits it
Infinity as I see it refers more to the true nature of reality. No one & no thing has any kind of separate inherent or intrinsic nature.
I am a librarian so I feel that Infinity is my business. I connect words that were written a thousand years ago. Also words that were written last week.
There is an infinity number of possibilities. Means I have no limits as a composer or performer.
Every single note that I choose to play in a song I could have played any of the other notes. Or the notes between the notes.
U know like in the blues
Infinity is something that
Goes on & on & is continuous
Does not have an end point
I can show you
My experience of Infinity
Infinity means numbers go on & on
Infinity generally speaking is a very precise mathematical concept
Infinity is pure fiction
An optical illusion
Before Einstein people believed that the speed of light is Infinity.
It is Instantaneous & Einstein explained speed of light is finite - It is very very fast the light but it is finite. So the integer is very very big.
Much bigger than the speed of light
But still finite
What we will be talking about we want to call near Infinity
It is something which actually does take place in our finite world
But it is so big
And complicated that complexity of it is approaching Infinity in practical terms
Now that we have computer it is time to get rid of
this illusion & start doing completely purely finite & discreet mathematics
Infinity is here to stay
I have spent years thinking about it
And I am no wiser
I am not an accountant
This is what we do
We deal with stuff like that we deal with questions like that
This is why people like me go into Mathematics
We got these different perspectives
We are going to be investigating tonight
Infinity looked up from the point of view of Philosophy Theology Mathematics & Physics
And we are going to try to wrap ourselves round all of that in the next 90 mins
So sit back & enjoy the ride
Ok we are going to begin with Philip Clayton
Philip is a Philosopher Theologian - He is a Provost of Claremont Lincoln University
He was the Principal Investigator of the Science & Spiritual Quest Program
He has written more than a dozen books in his field including Adventures in the Spirit
In Quest of Freedom & Religion & Science the basic
He has spoken about this all over the world
Philip take us from what we just seen
Infinity what an incredible concept
U can picture the earliest men & women staring up at the innumerable stars
Watching grains of sand slowly slide through their fingers
And think what is this thing without limit
I wanna take u on a brief little stroll through the history of the Infinite
Try to do that in a finite period of time
5 mins but lets see he is gonna watch me
And see if I can find a couple of Philosophers a couple of Thelogians
Maybe a representative of East & West
To give u some sense of the parameters  of this concept
If that is not a contradiction in terms
In some ways a vast variety of ways of conceiving the Infinite
In another sense a few core concepts that keep arising
That u will see over & over again
As we move through this evening
Lets start with Zeno of Elea
The Philosopher who gets credit for first introducing the concept of the Infinite in the West
Actually this is not quite right
because Anex & Manda had introduced the concept
a few years earlier of the Boundless
A pyron
The thing that is without limits
A scary kind of notion that the Greeks really disliked
U cant build a Parthenon with the Boundless right
Zeno found that whenever he introduced real infinites into the world
He ran into paradoxes
So lets take the fastest Greek of all Achilles
And lets set him in a foot race
Against a tortoise right
Can we give the tortoise a head start
Is that all right
So the tortoise is out there in front
An hour later he has made a hundred feet right
And here goes Achilles
Zeno says well he has gotta go half way to the tortoise first
And then he has gotta go half way there & the tortoise
And then he has gotta go half way
U get the point
Achilles Zeno argued could never pass the tortoise
If Infinites are real
Because he always has to transverse half the distance & half the distance
To the end
So the Infinite & paradox are linked from the very beginning
Lets move on to Pythagoras
We give Pythagoras credit for inventing the notion of Mathematics
Which by the way in Greek means That which can be learnt
He did it with a Quays eye religious orientation
Pythagoras said that each integer had some sort of philosophical or spiritual meaning
And the ratios between the integers are crucial
Seven eighths one fourth & so forth
So the harmonic progression was for them a religious insight
He launches the idea of the theorem & what is the most famous theorem from Pythagoras
The Pythagorean theorem right
And all of a sudden the whole project goes to hell in a hand basket
Right we have got an equal right angled triangle
One one so we can see one square plus one square equal two
equal c square so c equals the square root of two
But that is an irrational number
To write down the square root of two would take us infinite digits with no repeating pattern right
Right in the middle of the religion of the Infinite
Breaks out the impossible
The irrationality the religion of rationality
Shot to hell right at the
outset of the story
Lets step over to India for a moment & lets see how things look different over there
We go to the great founder of the Jain religion U know Ahimsa Martin Luther King Ghandi  Mahavira
The Jains weren't famous just for that though
They also did incredible speculation on the nature of Infinite
As far as we know
By 400 BC the Jains had introduced a notion that hadn't been used before
The difference between that which go on without ending
And the truly limitless
The truly endless
They also began to distinguish orders of Infinite
So there is Infinite in length
Infinite in area
Infinite in volume
And Infinite perpetually
Get the distinction
They are trying to give us orders of Infinite as they go
And the last thing for which we credit the Jains
When they distinguished between Enumerable Innumerable & Infinite
They said the highest Enumerable number
And they defined it the way that as we will hear in a moment
Cantor defined Aleph naught the first number of the transfinites
So amazing comprehension in India some 2400 years ago
All right Lets step back to the Greeks
And come to Aristotle the Father of some two dozen scientists
That crucial thinker
Aristotle realizes that with actual Infinities we are in deep doo doo
Basically Physics is not gona work well
So what he decides is that there exists no actual Infinite
We have to banish that concept from the physical world
If we are gona do good Science
So he says it is fine that we can have a potential Infinite
It just cant ever be actual
So for example the potential Infinite is start counting upward
U can go as long as u want to
But in a finite period of time
U only make it a finite distance
The world is only a finite number of years old he said
Therefore there are no actual Infinites
Take a quantity & start dividing
U can divide it as much as u want to
But at some point u will run out of time
As I am about to
And u have to stop
Aristotle launched this notion of potential of Infinity
All right lets finish up with three theologians & three radically different understandings of the Infinite
Lets go to the High Middle Ages the Scholastic Period & the greatest of thinkers Thomas Aquinas
Thomas Aquinas says as a Theologian I am interested in a different question
U all are interested in quantity
I am interested in a quality of existence
What mode of existence would God have that divine
God would be qualitatively Infinite
Which means God would be Insperfect thee si  mum
The most perfect being
It is a mode of existing a way of existing that sets God apart from anything else
Not quantity
So he bifurcates between the mathematical Infinite & the religious or philosophical Infinite
But still Aristotle rears his ugly head
Because even this Infinite God couldn't create an Infinite object
Because anything in the world must be by nature finite
Moving on from Aristotle to the 15th century we find the Bishop of Cologne Nicholas of Cusa
And here is a Theologian who decides he is gona go with the Infinite all the way
No restraint
So the Infinite what is that
It is that thing which has no limits
Therefore every thing must be included within the Infinite
Nothing can be excluded
The world itself must be within God
It might cost him his job
Mathematics love Nicholas de Cusa because he used Mathematical examples to describe the God world relation
So God is the circle whose center is everywhere
And whose circumference is therefore nowhere
Nothing is outside of God
And he said if u get that right it means a
coincidence of opposites
God world God human kind linked together
And he said we are the animal that stands at the boundary between the eternal & the finite
And finally let me close with that great heretic
The one that the modern thought love to hate Baruch Spinoza
A Jewish fascinating Jewish philosopher kicked out of the synagogue at aged 14 for allegedly saying that God has a body
Spinoza decided to write his metaphysic in the guise of geometry
Ethica More Geometrico - Ethics in the guise of Geometry
And u guys it is overwhelming compelling argument
If God is Infinite God is the One substance
There can be no other substances besides this One
The substance must have Infinite attributes
And we finite little beings cant be separate beings so we must be modes of the One
God however is not the transcendent God the personal God who does stuff
He used the phrase Deu Siva Latora God that is Nature
God & Nature become absolutely one for Spinoza
And the highest ethic is for u to live in accordance with the laws of Nature
To be a part of that One unfolding Infinite hold is our fate
Half the philosophers revere him as Science friendly
Half the philosophers revere him as Theological
For him it is the intellectual love of God to know nature to know yourself as part & parcel of Nature
And to behave together with Nature
The Infinite then focuses Spinoza from Theology back into the natural world
So Keith a short history of Infinity
Applause
Makes me feel nervous we are live streaming this
I am not quite sure who is listening in to this broadcast
As a simple Mathematician I am feeling quite nervous there
And I am gona very rapidly bring it back to my own comfort level
Coz my next guest is a regular practicing Mathematician like myself
It is Steven Strogatz one of the world's most highly cited Mathematician
His honours include the Presidential Young Investigator Award
A Lifetime Achievement Award for the communication of Mathematics for the general public
And membership in the American Academy of Arts & Sciences
He is currently a Professor of Applied Mathematics at Cornell
And his publications include Non Linear Dynamics
The Calculus of Friendship & wait for it The Joy of X
Steven
Thank you
Applause
Thank you very much Keith & thank you all for coming out
I like to as Keith said bring it back to Mathematics & for us in the Math world the really great transcendent hero of Infinity is Georg Cantor
Cantor lived in the Mid 1800s & came up with ideas that are so mind blowing
And so stunning that we are still kinda reverberating from his insights--=
We will be hearing about the disturbing things that he thought of
They are still so counter-intuitive that the Mathematicians & Physicists are really grappling with them even today
So the big insight from Cantor the biggest of all is that there are  different kinds of Infinity
Some Infinities can actually be bigger than others
And so I wana walk u through a few of his Mathematical arguments because they are so beautiful & so elegant
that if u haven't seen them I think they will change your life
And if you have seen them this is like listening to the greatest song your favourite song a second time I don't think u will mind
So but to set this up I want to
I am gona show u some visual version of what Cantor came up with
But first I think it is worth mentioning a little bit about his life
Because it was as with any great maverick there were people who opposed him
He was not regarded necessarily as a hero to all Mathematicians
In fact one of the greatest Mathematicians of his era
described Cantor's work as a disease
Ouch
Another one of his colleagues a Mathematician named Kronecker who was in a position of power in Berlin
Where Cantor very much wanted to be a Professor
He never got to be a Professor in Berlin
Kronecker wouldn't let him
Kronecker described Cantor as not only a charlatan but a corrupter of youths
Now I don't know what that makes me since I see there are some young people here & I will be talking about his work
Erm so yes corrupter of youth
Well actually this was no joke for Cantor because he as it turns out suffered from mental illness
It seems that he had depression I mean we know that he did have very significant bout of depression
May have had bipolar disorder
And he spent quite a few stints in sanatoria
It used to be thought that it was because of these attacks from Mathematicians that he was driven to this
But in more modern thinking probably he just had he suffered from depression
But didn't help that he was taking his withering criticism from so many people
On the other hand some of the other great Mathematicians of the time like a man named David Hilbert probably equalled to greatness as the two greatest of that era
Hilbert described Cantor's work as a paradise
And said nothing will ever expel us from this paradise Cantor has created
So let me introduce to u Cantor's paradise first by showing u some of the paradoxes
And really startling things that come about when u start thinking about Infinity mathematically
And the way we will do this is with a charming video that was produced by the Open University a couple of years ago
60 Seconds Adventures in Thought
Number 4 - Hilbert's Infinite Hotel
A grand hotel with an Infinite number of rooms
And an Infinite number of guests in those rooms
That was the idea of German Mathematician David Hilbert friend of Albert Enstein & enemy of chambermaids the world over
To challenge our ideas of Infinity he asked what happens if someone new comes along looking for a place to stay
Hilbert's answer is to make each guest shift along one room
The guest in room 1 moves to room 2 & so on
So the new guest will have a space in room 1 & the guest book will have an Infinite number of complaints
But what about  a coach containing an Infinite number of new guests pulls up
Surely he cant accommodate all of them
Hilbert frees up an Infinite number of rooms by asking the guests to move to the room number which is double their current one
Leaving the Infinitely many odd numbers free
Easy for the guest in room 1
Not so easy for the man in room eight million six hundred thousand five hundred & ninety seven
Hilbert's paradox has fascinated Mathematicians Physicists & Philosophers even Theologians
And they all agree u should get down early for breakfast
It is a brilliant video I hope u caught the main Mathematical points at the risk of over explaining I am just gona remind u  what u saw
That in Hilbert hotel which is this parable of Infinity
It has Infinitely many rooms & so as it was explained if another guest shows up u can still make room for that guest by shifting everyone over one room
And there is always room because there is Infinitely many rooms for them and then the new guest can go in room one
If a bus or the video has a coach even a bus with Infinitely many new guests is still not enough to cause trouble at the Hilbert hotel
Because u can shift all the current guests into the even rooms leaving the odd number rooms for the guests
So the question starts to become well if Infinity is really that big at the Hilbert hotel
Is there any number of guests that u couldn't accommodate at the hotel
I mean are there Infinities so big that even the Hilbert hotel would not fit them
And so Cantor worried about this & came up with an attempt to find an Infinity too big even for I mean he didn't think in terms of the Hilbert hotel
But let me illustrate that way by imagining a situation that if u are kinda a nasty Contrarian
U might think what if an Infinite number of buses each carrying an Infinite number of people show up
What will the night manager do with this
So let me illustrate in fact that problem can be solved at the Hilbert hotel that is no problem at all
And so here is the solution to it
Lets just visualise these people by showing a picture which will have a row containing all the Infinitely many guests
That would correspond to bus number one
And then there is bus number two
Each with its Infinite number of guests which I am gona depict as faces
And then there is an Infinite number of of these buses
Its not supposed to be just 4 by 4
u are supposed to picture it with Infinitely many guests in each row & Infinitely many buses
(Keith ) The audience probably cant see but from my position I can see dots at the end of those rows
Yes thank u right
So those three dots are supposed to indicate that both the rows & buses go on in all directions
The first inexperienced manager might attempt to solve the problem this way
I mean what the goal is is to assign each passenger a room
And the problem will be solved if for any given passenger u can say
That person is in a room with a finite number a specific number
Like imagine a guest list & I can say oh yes Mr Smith u are gona be in room 133
As long as everybody has a room everybody is happy
Here is the first attempt to put people into rooms
Let me put Person 1 from Bus 1 in Room 1
And then I will put the second person from that same bus in Room 2
Third person in Room 3 u can see the this is not a good solution
Do u see what the problem is
No one in Bus 2 is gona be happy
Because the whole hotel will just be filled with passengers from Bus 1 & so u have infinitely many bus loads of infinitely many unhappy people
This is not what u want at your hotel
So that is not a good solution to the problem
But there is a much more clever way of doing it which then does accommodate everyone
What u do notice this zig zagging pattern of arrows
U start with the first person
That person gets Room 1 the second person is at the end of the first arrow
So it would be passenger 2 from Bus 1
Then u go down to Bus 2 Passenger 1 that person gets Room 3
Just follow the arrows & that is the order which people are placed into rooms
Can u sort of see what is happening how it is fanning out from the corner
And that will have the property that u can pick any person in that Infinite array & that person will be served in a finite time
They will have a room
So this is a way of actually accommodating Infinitely many people in Infinitely many buses in the Hilbert hotel
This raises the by the way I should say that there is the abstract version of this which is that this shows that the fractions
The positive fractions
Starting u know like well not starting but think about any fraction one third one fifth two eighth
U know don't worry about lowest terms
Four seventh Four seventeenth
Any fraction u can think of would correspond to one of these passengers
Like the person in Bus 4
A passenger 17
That might be what we would call four seventeenth
I mean that is a correspondence between the people in these diagrams & the positive fractions
And so this argument that I have given u here is essentially Cantor's argument for showing that the positive fractions can be counted
In the sense that they can be put into what Cantor called the one-to-one correspondence
With the natural counting number the numbers 1 2 3 4
There is a way of listing all positive fractions so that we can say this is the first one this is the second one this is the third one
And every positive fraction will be at some finite place in that list
They are not ordered by size by the way they are ordered in this way that I just described in this zig zagging pattern
So the rational numbers the fractions are countable meaning they can be put into one-to-one correspondence with the natural numbers 1 2 3 4 & so on
And this raised the question in Cantor's mind it seems like everything he could think of is countable
Every Infinity he could think of was countable or to put in another way
The Hilbert hotel really lives up to its model - There is always room at the Hilbert hotel
Well actually though in 1873 Cantor discovered an amazing example showing that that was not true
That there was an Infinity that is so big that it would defeat the Hilbert hotel no matter how clever the manager is
And this would has to do with the amount of Infinity contained in a continuous line
If u imagined the number line the u know traditional number line that was tagged on the wall with your elementary school
And shows the integers 1 2 3 4 & there is all the space in between where all the fractions & irrational numbers are
That continuous line what we think of it as the real numbers
If the real numbers showed up at the hotel
There wouldn't be room for all of them
And here is the proof
This is Cantor's famous diagonal proof
He said imagine there was a roster a sort of a guest list
And this was a guest list it is gona be approved by contradiction
I will show that there is a real number that doesn't have a room
Here is a putative list
Where room 1 assigned to this real number that is being shown on here .42 etc
And room 2 is assigned to some other  real number don't worry about the details of number
The idea is just to imagine a whole list of all the real numbers just like we could list all the rational numbers
Maybe we could list all the real numbers
Well Cantor's argument is no because if there were such a list and here is an attempt to show what it might look like
U then circle the first digit of the first number I don't know if u can see there is a little circle around that 4
And then u circle the second digit of the second number 2
And the third digit of the third number 1
So from that u construct the real number which in this case would be point 4 2 1 and so on
That is not the problem that is not the bad number
What we then do is change each of those digits in that number
Like the 4 that begins this number
Maybe make it a 3
Or just whatever u want just change it
Or the 2  that is the second digit make it something else make it a 7
Just have some system
But the rule is u construct this number down the diagonal & u systematically change its nth digit
To something else
That is if it is the nth number the nth digit gets changed
And so by doing that Cantor constructs a number which is not in the list
Because it cant be the first number in the list coz it differs from the first number in the first place
It is not the second number in the list coz it differs from the second number in the second place
And so on
So by systematically going down the diagonal & then changing every digit
He has now produced a number that is not on the list
And this argument
Shows that in fact that real numbers cannot be counted
There is no list that can embrace them all
And so with that comes the question then
This very nagging question that we are gona be talking about next
Which is
Well if there are now 2 kinds of infinity
The countable kind & this continuous kind which is bigger
Are there other Infinities
And really more to the point
Is there some Infinity that is sandwiched in between them
Is there some Infinity smaller than the continuous Infinity but bigger than the Infinity of the 1 2 3 variety
That is called the Continuum Hypothesis
The idea that there is no such Infinity in between
It was Cantor's great conjecture
But he never proved it
Maybe Keith will tell us a little about his own experience with the Continuum Hypothesis
Yeah because earlier on in my career I actually went into set theory coz I got seduced by what happened next
And here is what happened next
In 1940 an Austrian Mathematician called Kurt Godel showed this practised conjecture Continuum Hypothesis that there is no Infinity between the natural numbers & the real numbers
Godel showed that that conjecture could not be proved false
OK u might say
It means it is gona be true right
Well no because in 1963 an American Mathematician called Paul Cohen showed u couldn't prove it could be true
Cant prove it is false
Cant prove it is true
it is independence of the axioms that we take of Mathematics
And as a graduate student beginning at the very end of the 1960s
I think this was significant that this was in the 1960s - People were hiring all sorts of all things
High enough to  try to go into Infinity
There was a question of
We soon realized we had a technique called Forcing that allowed us to construct alternative set theories
Alternative mathematics
In which u could prove things true not true or neither of them
U could prove things independent
Un like many mathematicians of my generation I got seduced by that kind of question
And we used cohens technique in particular & sort of Godels technique
In order to investigate all sorts of universities
And it was a wild period
But it was a period that was eventually gona get tamed
And I think it was gona get tamed by I would say it has been tamed
To a large extent by our next guest
Who is William Hugh Woodin
Set theorist at the University of California Berkeley
Large cardinal in my business
Does not mean a large portly gentleman in a uniform
That is his business
A large cardinal is an infinite an infinity
So the infinity of a very large size
Hugh Woodin has a large cardinal named after him called The Woodin Cardinal
He has made many notable contributions to the theory of Inner models & Determinacy
I think of him as a mathematical equivalent of Physics
Who has invented 21st century mathematics
Dropped into the end of 20th century
Hugh take us from there
Applause
Thank u for that introduction
Thank u all for being here
So I spent my life trying to solve the Continuum Hypothesis
Now we just heard that u cant prove it true
U cannot prove it false
It doesn't mean it doesn't have a solution
It just means we don't have all the principles yet
So that is the question
Are we missing the key principles or the principles defined
That will enable us to determine whether the Continuum Hypothesis is true or false
Or maybe there is a much stronger version of Collins Theorem that shows there really is no answer
So really the fundamental question is this
We have this conception of Mathematically Infinity
And it is embodied in our conception of the universe of sets